thémines et puis c'est madame simone
weil ministre de la santé et de la
famille qui traitera d'un sujet bien
connu et qui va rester longtemps à
l'ordre du jour comment réduire ou en
tout cas modérer les dépenses de
l'assurance maladie vous vous souvenez
qu'à la mi-décembre quand la décision a
été prise d'augmenter les cotisations de
la sécurité sociale madame veil ici même
d'ailleurs avait parlé entre autres de
l'auto discipline indispensable du corps
médical elle avait évoqué la possibilité
de sanctionner les praticiens abusif
même si avait-elle ajouté ces derniers
sont peu nombreux alors voyons où nous
en sommes sur ce point avec daniel bigot
les prestations des médecins c'est en
effet la cible numéro 1 du gouvernement
pour réduire les dépenses de santé le
but est double stopper la
surconsommation des médicaments et faire
la chasse aux ordonnances de
complaisance comment est bien un système
d'auto discipline va être mise en place
avec l'accord des syndicats du corps
médical dorénavant chaque médecin aura
son dossier ses prestations c'est à dire
le nombre de ces consultations et la
longueur de ces ordonnances seront
comparées chaque année à une moyenne
établie grâce aux statistiques des
caisses d'assurance maladie dès qu'un
médecin s'écartera de trop de cette
moyenne il sera rappelé à l'ordre par
une commission départementale composée
de responsables médicaux et de la
sécurité sociale en cas de récidive la
sanction ira jusqu'aux des
conventionnement du médecin c'est à dire
à la suppression du remboursement de ses
actes la cible numéro deux les dépenses
d'hospitalisation
elles représentent actuellement plus de
la moitié des dépenses de santé objectif
réduire de 3 % les dépenses en trois ans
plusieurs mesures sont à l'étude
premièrement stabilisation voire
réduction du nombre de lits
paradoxalement certaines régions sont
suréquipés deuxièmement limitation de la
durée d'hospitalisation les frais
d'hospitalisation étant calculée à la
journée certains hôpitaux ont tendance à
prolonger inutilement le séjour à
l'hôpital troisièmement meilleure
gestion du personnel les dépenses du
personnel représentent actuellement 70%
des dépenses hospitalières en marge de
ces mesures d'autres sont en préparation
un projet vise les facultés de médecine
pour une sélection renforcée des
étudiants à la fin de la première année
au rythme actuel en 1982 la france aura
le taux de médecins le plus élevés
d'europe et puis le second projet vise
la consommation pharmaceutique avec le
lancement d'une campagne d'information
auprès du public et la limitation de la
publicité pharmaceutique
l'enjeu de toutes ces mesures c'est la
survie même du système de la sécurité
sociale qui enregistrera rappelons le un
déficit de 15 milliards de francs pour
78 79 déjà la mi décembre le
gouvernement a pris une première série
de mesures dont le but est d'augmenter
les recettes demain il s'attaquera donc
aux dépenses de santé seuls leurs
limitations peut assurer une solution à
long terme mais l'effort à faire est
considérable entre 69 et 77 les dépenses
de santé autant augmenté de 18 % chaque
année